can you off the top of your head can you
think of you talk to you compared you
know the finite mindset to some things
with law enforcement sure as far as
infinite can you think of anything off
the top of your head where you could
relate that specifically to what we do
and what that might look like anybody
who's wearing a uniform here knows this
because you've had this experience in
your career right which is treating
someone with dignity
treating someone with dignity has
nothing to do
whether they are guilty or innocent
right
that everybody here knows that when you
treat somebody with dignity the way they
respond to you even if they've committed
a crime and they're sitting there in
handcuffs is very very different than
when we don't treat them with dignity so
for example treating someone with
dignity may look like
somebody gets pulled over for expired
tags or something and you've they've got
a warrant i don't know and you have to
tow their car right
so you call a tow truck and now somebody
who's maybe financially struggling
you've just put at least 300
more that they have to deal with
or treating them with dignity is like
hey
i gotta i gotta tell your car before i
call a tow truck do you wanna call
somebody you wanna call a family member
or something who can come here and get
your car um that'll save you 300 bucks
you know and help you out
you know and if you can't call somebody
i'm gonna have to tow it right that's
treating someone with dignity and
everybody here knows that when you treat
somebody with dignity sometimes you're
taking them to jail and they thank you
and the way in which people respond to
the uniform if treated with dignity has
nothing to do with breaking the law or
being put in handcuffs it's how it's
it's human being to human being and so
i think in a law enforcement when law
enforcement is conducted in the policing
organization you're thinking about the
longevity of the value of the uniform
you're thinking about the relationship
of of the the those who wear the uniform
in in public how much the public is
willing to help us if a crime is
committed and we go to the public and
say can you help us and their
willingness
those those things are determined right
now on a day-to-day basis right it and
you you asked before about building of
trust right trust does there's no big
thing you can do that builds trust trust
is built up with lots and lots and lots
of tiny little innocuous little things
think of it like your own relationship
like you know have you ever been in love
the person who fell in love with you
there wasn't like i i bought you flowers
on valentine's day now you love me
that's not how it works it's like you
know i went to the fridge to get myself
a drink and i got you one too without
you asking i woke up in the morning and
i said good morning to you before i
checked my phone
there was a game on and you said honey
can i talk to you and i paused the game
and said what's on your mind right yeah
i'm being idealistic
um uh
my point is is no one of those things
made someone fall in love or trust you
but it's the combination and
accumulation of all those tiny little
individually innocuous things that we
say i believe you and i trust you
now imagine an entire organization where
we're just trying to do our job we just
have to enforce the law we have to do
these things these are the rules this is
how we do it but the manner in which we
conduct ourselves each one innocuous
unto itself
over the course of time builds
tremendous trust
with an organization and the community
so that when you need to pull from that
trust bank when you need to
make a make a make a withdrawal
right because something's gone really
horribly wrong and maybe there was
somebody who acted illegally within the
department
that you get to say to the community we
screwed up and i need your help to be
patient they go
you're good
you're good but that that trust has
earned